UPDATE FROM THE CARAVAN OF
MIGRANTS DEMANDING ENTRY ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
SIT TIGHT, IT IS TIME FOR THE
BREAKING NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
WE START WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT,
ABSOLUTELY ZERO EVIDENCE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP EVER COLLUDED
WITH RUSSIA AND ANY, WAY, SHAPE,
FORM.
AND ROBERT MUELLER'S MERRY BAN
OF TRUMP HATING SYCOPHANTS ARE
COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY DESPERATE
TO FIND ANYTHING, SOMETHING ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LATE LAST NIGHT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RELEASED A
REPORT ALLEGEDLY DETAILING
QUESTIONS THAT ROBERT MUELLER
WANTS TO ASK TRUMP BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION CONCLUDES.
IF ANY OF THESE QUESTIONS ARE
TRUE, BE WARNED, MUELLER IS
LAYING A HUGE PERJURY TRAP FOR
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WHICH MEANS TWO THINGS, ONE, HE
HAS NOTHING.
AND TWO, IT PROVES EVERYTHING I
HAVE BEEN SAYING ABOUT HIM AND
ANDREW WEISSMANN AND COMPANY.
TWO OF AMERICA'S TOP ATTORNEYS
ARE NOW SOUNDING THE ALARM.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE QUESTIONS ARE INARTFULLY
DRAWN, THEY ARE WRITTEN AS
THEY ARE NOT CROSS EXAMINATION
QUESTIONS.
THEY ARE NOT SHARP QUESTIONS
DESIGNED TO CONFRONT AND TEST.
THEY ARE REALLY DESIGNED TO LET
HIM RAMBLE AND TALK.
I SUSPECT THAT THAT IS THE
STRATEGY OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL,
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THE DATA
MAY BE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
WEAKNESS.
IF THEY WERE TO ASK HIM DIRECT,
TOUGH, QUESTIONS TO WHICH YOU
COULD ANSWER YES OR NO, THAT
MIGHT NOT GIVE THEM THE
ADVANTAGE THAT THEY ARE
SEEKING.
>> THE QUESTIONS ARE AN
INTRUSION INTO THE PRESIDENT'S
ARTICLE TWO POWERS UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION TO FIRE ANY
EXECUTIVE BRANCH EMPLOYEE.
TO ASK QUESTIONS AS MR. MUELLER
APPARENTLY PROCESSED TO DO ABOUT
WHAT THE PRESIDENT WAS THINKING
WHEN HE FIRED COMEY OR FLYNN OR
ANYBODY ELSE IS IN OUTRAGEOUS
SOPHOMORIC, JUVENILE INTRUSION
INTO THE PRESIDENT'S UNFETTERED
POWER TO FIRE ANYONE IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
IT IS A SYMPTOM OF HOW
RIDICULOUS THIS APPOINTMENT WAS
BY ROD ROSENSTEIN WHEN HE MADE
THE APPOINTMENT WITH NO EVIDENCE
OF A CRIME.
>> Sean: THEY ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
THIS IS A PERJURY TRAP FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND EVEN MORE FRIGHTENING THE
CONTENTS OF THIS INQUIRY.
NOTING ALL OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
INCLUDE THE TERM WHAT DID THE
PRESIDENT THINK?
WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT THINK
ABOUT JAMES COMEY, WHAT DID THE
PRESIDENT THINK ABOUT JEFF
SESSIONS RECUSAL?
WHAT DOES HE THINK ABOUT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, WELL, I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR ROBERT MUELLER,
WHEN DID THINKING OR THOUGHTS
EVER BECOME A CRIME?
WHEN DID THE UNITED STATES START
REGULATING WHAT YOU MAY OR MAY
NOT TO BE IN A PERSON'S MIND?
ARE WE GOING TO CRIMINALIZE
THOUGHTS?
THIS LIST OF INSANE, JUVENILE
RIDICULOUS QUESTIONS GOES ON
INCLUDING ONE ABOUT A STATEMENT
TO OUR FRIEND MARIA BARROW TO
LOBO, THE REACTION TO NEWS
REPORTS.
AND WHAT DISCUSSIONS TRUMP HAD
ABOUT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
HE NEVER TERMINATED HIM!
AND MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
THOUGHT PROCESS.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
ORIGINALLY WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT RUSSIA COLLUSION AND
INVESTIGATION.
NOT TO SOME PERSECUTION OF THE
PRESIDENT ON RIDICULOUS THOUGHT
PATTERNS.
RUSH LIMBAUGH CAPTURED IT WELL
TODAY.
HE SAID THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
ONLY AGREE TO A MUELLER
INTERVIEW IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
GETS THE HILLARY CLINTON
TREATMENT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF TRUMP COULD SECURE THE
SAME IDENTICAL CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT WERE GRANTED TO
HILLARY CLINTON, THEN WHY NOT
SIT DOWN FOR THE INTERVIEW AND
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS?
BUT OF COURSE I SPEAK
FACETIOUSLY, BECAUSE EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT DONALD TRUMP IS NOT
GOING TO GET TO THE
HILLARY CLINTON TREATMENT
EXTENDED BY JAMES COMEY.
>> Sean: NOT UNDER OATH, NOT
RECORDED, MEANINGLESS, SEND IN A
PRO TRUMP PERSON LIKE PETER
STRZOK INTERVIEWED HILLARY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY GET THE HILLARY
TREATMENT FOR ANY INTERVIEW WITH
THE FBI.
AND JUST LIKE HILLARY CLINTON'S
INTERVIEW, AFTER THE EXONERATION
WAS WRITTEN A MONTH LATER, OH,
TERMS INTERVIEW SHOULD BE
CONDUCTED NOT UNDER OATH, NOT
RECORDED, NOT BE TRANSCRIBED,
AND THE EXONERATION WRITTEN
MONTHS IN ADVANCE.
AND OH COMING OUT, SOMEBODY WITH
A PRO TRUMP BIAS, LET'S SAY, ME,
I WILL CONDUCT THE QUESTIONING.
HOW ABOUT RUSH, OR MARK LEVINE,
GOOD IDEA.
NOW TO GET THE TREATMENT OR
PETER STRZOK, MAYBE, I DON'T
KNOW, WE HAVE A GOOD CHOICE OF
PEOPLE, LOTS OF CONSERVATIVES
THAT CAN INTERVIEW.
NONE OF THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE KNOW THAT.
WE KNOW SADLY IN AMERICA WE HAVE
A 2-TEAR JUSTICE SYSTEM, NOT
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT IS TARGETED
IN A TOTALLY OFF THE RAILS
WITCH HUNT, HILLARY CLINTON,
JAMES COMEY, ANDREW McCABE,
ALL OF THESE OTHER DEEP STATE
ACTORS HAVE NEVER BEEN CHARGED
WITH A CRIME.
DESPITE MOUNTAINS OF EVIDENCE
THAT WE HAVE.
DESPITE HER TOTAL EXONERATION
FROM THE FBI, OUR FRIEND,
FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYSTS
GREGG JARRETT WILL JOIN US,
REVEALING MULTIPLE SERIOUS
CRIMES THAT HILLARY CLINTON
SHOULD BE CHARGED WITH.
STARTING WITH 18793, MISHANDLING
AND DESTROYING DOCUMENTS.
THE OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
REMEMBER, BLEACH PAGE, DELETED
EMAILS, BUSTED UP DEVICES.
NO CHARGES OVER THE MULTIPLE
CRIMES RELATED TO HER CAMPAIGN
SHADY PRACTICES RELATING TO THE
STEELE DOSSIER.
WE WILL LOOK AT JAMES COMEY, NOT
UNDER ANY INVESTIGATION AS OF
NOW PRODUCTION AND HE AT LEAST
FACE SCREAMED HE OVER 18 UFC 61,
THE GOVERNMENT PROPERTY OF
RECORDS AFTER HE TOOK THE MEMO
OUTSIDE OF THE FBI.
WHAT ABOUT USC 1924?
THE MISHANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
AND REMEMBER, WHEN JAMES COMEY
LIED TO CONGRESS ABOUT NIGHT
SIGNING OFF ON THE EXONERATION
LETTER ONCE BEFORE THAT
INTERVIEW TOOK PLACE, THAT IS
AGAINST THE LAW, 18 USC 1621.
AND WE HAVE ANDREW McCABE,
HOUSE REPUBLICANS HAVE REFERRED
TO HIM AS THE DIG FOR MULTIPLE
CRIMES OVER LYING TO FBI AND
McCABE WAS FIRED FOR LYING TO
THE FBI.
LET'S SEE, OH, GENERAL FLYNN?
WHY HAS HE NOT BEEN CHARGED WITH
A CRIME IN THIS CASE?
DO NOT HOLD YOUR BREATH FOR A
INVESTIGATION INTO LORETTA
LYNCH, LISA PAGE, PETER STRZOK
OR ANY ANTI-TRUMP DEEP STATE
ACTORS.
WHAT IS BEHIND THIS SADLY IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA TODAY
IS A 2-TIERED SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
IT IS SIMPLE, THE DEEP STATE
HATES WHO YOU CHOSE TO BE YOUR
PRESIDENT.